Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Netflix just released the first squid game season
two trailer
And just like season one, it'll probably be
the most messed up best thing you will watch this year.
Separately, they released a couple other preview scenes
that explain a little bit more of the plot
during season two.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
cannot wait to see how messed up it is going to be.
they don't give a specific release
date in this trailer.
But right now, best guess is the end of the summer
or the end of the year.
Like much later
this year, the trailer starts with Sam get hung
talking to who sounds like the front man
who's telling him he's going to regret his decision
The whole idea is, is his decision to reenter the games
or try to join the organization
and that's running the games so that he can try and
take it down or get a chance to try and take it down.
and it
sounds like at least at the beginning of the season,
the front man has no interest in helping him
take down the games.
But that might change during the course of the season.
It depends on what the front man's
arc is going to be in season two.
but I think the whole idea is that
they're talking on the phone.
It sounds like he's in communication with him
behind the scenes.
So the front man's role in his gambit to take down
the games would just become a much bigger subplot,
like he will actually help him destroy the games
or he might become the villain of season two.
when they started
revealing the Frontman's backstory during season one,
they implied that he was only working for the games
because he felt trapped in that lifestyle
and his brother had been looking for him.
like something happened to him.
He got into the games,
but then got stuck in the games like he never left.
he basically won a previous version of the games
at some point and then just went on to work
for the organization that was running the games,
like he become trapped in that lifestyle.
it wasn't totally clear
if he completely drunk the Kool-Aid, though.
and it just sounds like Jihan is planning
to do something similar to that as well.
Like that
will make it easier for them to help each other out.
If the front man is going to help him,
like he'll try to work for the organization.
Maybe They're only couple of ways
that he could take down the games.
He didn't have to rejoin the games again,
or he'd have to join the organization
that's running the games. end. Even though the old man.
ill nom died.
There's still several people who had taken over
administration of the games after his death.
But the games themselves didn't slow a beat.
He'd set everything up
so that they would continue after his death.
He'd known he was dying for a long time.
So it sounds like the Frontman's role
has become much more prominent in that organization.
merrily, Assumption, just
based on the pacing of season one, is
that he'll be able to either
reenter the games themselves or join the organization
running the games by the end of episode one.
In episode one will just play similarly to season one,
Episode one, where you see what his life is like post
games outside in the regular world as he drives himself
crazy trying to figure out how to take them down.
we got a couple scenes of his life outside of the games
at the very end of season
one, just based on the other scenes
that they released previews for.
It looks like he's able to find the salesman,
like the recruiter again,
the person who acts as a recruiter for the games.
Since he's in communication with the games,
he know how to find them
during one of those final scenes in season one,
he saw the recruiter in the middle of recruiting
another random person on the street like he'd
been recruited at the beginning of the season.
As he rushed to try and stop them,
the recruiter had been able to take off,
but he did take the contact card
for the games from the man.
So that's probably what leads him to the recruiter
after this, because you see them sitting here, zoom in.
Enhanced notice
that the recruiter has a gun at the table.
maybe he makes him play
another game in order to get his help
to get back into the games
or back into that organization.
That look on his face makes it seem like he's
kind of reluctant or he's kind of bummed out
that he wants back in the game
so badly or knows what he plans to do.
Like he could just see it on his face,
like his look of determination
and thinks that he's just heading to his death
like you won once, but you won't be able to win twice
or you won't be able to take down this organization.
It's too secure, is too big.
there's another picture of him
looking at one of the workers
from the games wearing one of those same outfits
with the shapes over the mask.
It almost looks like he's inside a club, though,
with a bunch of regular people
who are not wearing masks or outfits like this.
so. Maybe this is a random person
who works for the games or used to
and you're seeing him randomly outside of the games.
Like what the hell?
Like the look on his face is so quizzical,
like he has no idea what's going on.
It might even be a hallucination.
Or maybe it's somebody that works for the games
randomly that just happens to be here
wearing his outfit.
something makes it seem, though,
that the games themselves wouldn't allow their workers
to do stuff like this, like they killed their workers
all the time during the game.
The game itself was just as deadly to the workers
as it was the actual players.
there's another scene with this woman played by Park
Yu Young.
She's playing a totally new character
during season two, and it looks like she's
just another person who's won the recruiter's game
and earned a ticket to the games.
And she's staring at the card thinking about
whether or not she's actually going to go to the games.
she's still wearing her street clothes.
So she hasn't made it there yet.
She looks none the worse for wear.
My only theory is that these previewed her character
with the other main characters
because she's super important this season.
Like another down on your luck kind of person.
Do they want you to root for Maybe.
Maybe they have her be the winner of this new round of
games, so she's busy trying to win the actual games.
While Maggie Hunt is busy trying to destroy
the company, running the games, and get the front man
to either help him or stop the front man himself
if he becomes the main villain of the season.
remember,
things could go the other way with the front man.
They kind of teased a possible redemption arc for him,
though so could go either way with his character.
Let me know in the comments
if you think the front man
will actually try to turn good and help him
or they'll just make him the main villain of the season
structure of the corporation that they use to run
the games is heavily compartmentalized,
so people only know what they need to know
for whatever task it is that they're hired for
And you find that many of the workers are barely
any better off than the contestants themselves,
with many of them being killed
for violating the rules of the games.
Just like the contestants.
You also probably noticed the shapes on all the workers
masks.
The triangles circle squares all correspond to shapes
taken from the shape of the squid game court.
The actual squid game logo is also depicted
as the hair clip on the giant doll in the first game
during that first recruitment slap game
that everyone plays, all the contestants
always choose the blue tile, even when they get to play
another round, And here's another big one too.
Most of the characters who wind up dying big WTF does
foreshadow their own deaths in really karmic ways.
Karma does play a big role in the series.
Alley steals from his boss
even though he was owed all that money,
but then later winds up being betrayed by saying Woo,
who steals all of his marbles?
Duke Sue jumps off a bridge to avoid being killed
by gang members and then later himself dies.
After stepping off the glass bridge, early
on, the female main character threatens
to slash a man's throat,
then later dies after saying Woo slashes her throat.
saying Woo woo, who had previously tried to kill
himself, later saves his friend the main character
by sacrificing himself
main character even swears on his own mother's life,
then finds that after he's won the game
and return to their apartment, she's died
also during the final episode,
he winds up asking that banker to borrow 10,000 won,
which is another callback to the time at the racetrack
retry to get his 10,000
won back from the attendant like,
hey, could I get that back, please?
when the police officers rifling
through all the files on the Squid Game Corporation,
he finds that the games actually started in 1988
because that's when the first winner was crowned.
it even though the old man dies in the finale,
the other businessmen still continue the games
as if nothing has changed in
the front man is still alive doing his job.
not really an Easter egg but really WTF moment
that was also revealed by the creator.
he said that making the series was so stressful
that he lost six teeth.
So it's almost like he himself
was playing a squid game of sorts.
but if you spotted any big Easter eggs or WTF moments
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below in the comments.
was probably going to happen
is we'll get that full trailer by this summer
but they might drop a few more teasers before then.
Next week is the Super Bowl or if you live outside
the United States, the American Super Bowl,
which tends to be trailer fest,
like there are so many trailers for so many big things.
I'll try to do videos for like all the really big stuff
we should
be getting that first big Deadpool
three trailer with Wolverine.
That'll give us a better idea
of what the actual story is.
I've done a couple of teaser videos
because they've been releasing footage for a while,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of those
because there's going to be a bunch of big stuff
coming
Click here for that last big Deadpool
3 teaser trailer
and click here
for all the big Easter Eggs from Squid game season one.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!